[Musique]
le partenariat entre le département et
l'Office National des Forêts a été
renforcée ce mercredi 7 juin par une
signature de convention avec le soutien
de l'État par la présence de Jérôme
philippini préfet de la Réunion
est heureux d'accompagner
l'Office National des Forêts c'est un
opérateur d'État et il a un rôle
historique fondamental à la Réunion
c'est le partenaire principal du conseil
départemental et c'est celui qui
garantit que l'on préserve ici cette
magnifique réserve de biodiversité qui
est notre forêt une signature qui marque
la continuité de ce partenariat
historique mais qui prévoit également
des évolutions
dans mes révolution c'est c'est on
augmente le périmètre qui embarque
maintenant à la fois les forêts de
particules comme c'était le cas avant
mais également les forêts
départementales et de manière qui permet
au département de se donner la
possibilité
d'intervenir de participer à des
activités en forêt de manière ensuite un
engagement plus important au niveau
technique et démarche stratégique des
services du département dans ce
partenariat qui en fait maintenant un
vrai partenariat politique avec une
expression de la vision stratégique de
l'appartement il y avait une déclinaison
par nos services dans le cadre de cette
convention et enfin
une révision des plantes financement des
activités majeures dans en
œuvre en fait à la Réunion notamment à
la lutte contre les invasive les
programmes de d'accueil d'insertion
l'entretien des sentiers ou un plan de
financement a été révisé avec une
participation supplémentaire du
département mais également de l'État
parmi les ambitions du département le
président souhaite donner une nouvelle
dimension à la production de bois et à
sa transformation à la Réunion
à travers ce nouveau partenariat ce que
je veux c'est qu'il y ait une nouvelle
ambition pour la forêt réunionnaise
parce que la forêt réunionnaise le bois
Réunionnais a longtemps servi dans une
forme d'industrie du bois ici à la
Réunion matière de bénisteries notamment
dans les constructions de cases et bien
il faut redonner une dimension à la
conforesterie je voudrais que les
entreprises réunionnaises puissent
trouver du bois réunionnais pour
construire par exemple des cases
utilisez le bois pour le coffrage je
voudrais que les familles qui
travaillent de l'ébénisterie puissent
trouver des bois comme le bois de
Tamarin pour réaliser des meubles des
meubles créoles que nous ayant bien
qu'on veut retrouver dans les cases de
la Réunion
le partenariat département ONF remonte à
1946 date de la départementalisation
[Musique]